this is a production of Cornell
University so today I'm going to
actually I'm going to tell you a story
about rice and water I think that's an
appropriate story to tell
so rice and water so rice is a perennial
semi aquatic plant it covers 10% of
Earth's arable land and most rice has
grown on farms that are less than a
hectare in size that's about 82 percent
of the rice on the planet and over 90%
is consumed within the country where
it's produced and those statistics
should tell you quite a bit already
about what I'm going to situate you for
which is if most rice is grown and
consumed locally and not traded
internationally that leads to much
greater diversity in terms of the
landscape rice production in terms of
countries the three largest countries in
the world account for over 50% of rice
produced that's China India and
Indonesia and when you look at this
little map showing where across the
globe we have rice production I hope
that little red spot comes forward
that's a real reason why China and India
out produce other countries it's not
because of the landmass it's because
those red areas signify that they get
three seasons per year so three crops on
the same land and you'll notice if you
look across the the blue is showing you
the areas that produce two crops per
year and the green is areas that produce
only one now in in Asia which is where
the majority of rice is grown what you
see is also that within those countries
that are producing the majority of the
world's rice there are a vast number of
different varieties in fact thousands of
varieties are produced every year and
because as I said they're consumed
produced and consumed locally every
locale in much of the rice growing world
has its own favorite Rice's and they
don't really trade their Rice's widely
so if you go from village to build
you will be treated to Rice's and
cuisines that have evolved with those
Rice's that are unique to that village
and that leads to preferences that have
to do with quality as well as to the
biology or the adapt it constraints of
the region where they're grown now it's
interesting to note that the
relationship between production and
export is quite unequal and so what you
see here are there's only 10% of rice
that's exported from any country so it's
a very inelastic supply there's always
more demand for importation of rice and
there is rice in the export market but
you see that there are two countries
that predominate that's India and
Thailand and Vietnam being a close third
and the reason is because there are
really only two types of rice that are
exported in any large quantity many of
you sitting here will know which those
are they're the two what we call supreme
quality Rice's on the international
market basmati and Thai jasmine and
those two Rice's alone account for over
80% of rice that's exported because
people are looking to pay for high
quality rice on the export market even
as countries like India are importing
lower quality rice to feed their people
so it's a very interesting kind of
market that we have and it's unlike that
of the other major cereals wheat or
maize for instance are normally very big
commodities in the international market
and they're not prized so much for their
local attributes in terms of cuisine now
the other thing about rice that I think
is very interesting is that we have
these different eco types and a lot of a
genetic diversity of rice is partitioned
partly because it's an in breeding
species and partly because they're
adaptations and whole germ polls gene
pools that are adapted to these
different rice ecotypes so this is about
rice and water so I've divided it into
the dry and the wet and on the dry side
we have the upland rice which accounts
for only about 9% of the land that's
used to produce it the rain-fed lowland
rice which we call dry rice because it's
completely dependent on rainfall
sometimes it's too wet but often it's
too dry and then there are the wet
Rice's and you'll see from this you know
topography topographical map that when
you get into the wet Rice's these are
Rice's that this is that semi-aquatic
nature coming forward you have the
irrigated paddy rice which accounts for
about 50% of the land planted to rice
you have the flooded de croo which is a
it's it's an idea that rice is planted
on the shores of rivers in the rivers
flood every year and also it's often
planted on the shores of of the sea and
so these are saline type Rice's as well
so mangrove swamps and areas that flood
periodically and then you have the deep
water rice and we published a paper
about a month or two ago in science
about the mechanism of deep water rice
where Rice's can rise very very rapidly
to keep up with with with flood floods
that come and stay for months at a time
but the interesting thing about the the
talk I'm going to give today is not
going to talk at all about the deep
water rice which has grown on only 5% of
the land I'm going to talk more about
the problems that we're facing as a
community as we think about maintaining
rice production into the future so
irrigated paddy accounts for production
on about 50% of the acreage that's
planted to rice but it accounts for 75%
of the rice that's produced so it's a
very very productive ecosystem it
requires that you have control of water
so the concept of irrigation is not just
that it's standing water but you can put
water on and take water off it will now
normally you do not plant into standing
water you plant into very low low paddy
soil and then you bring the water up and
then of course before you harvest rice
you have to be able to take the water
off and dry it down and the future part
of the futures discussions that are
going on in the international community
is about the concept of what we call
alternate wetting and drying where you
really need control over water you can
bring it in and pick it off and you can
actually pull the water off midseason
and that stimulates a lot of root growth
and it stimulates
in some cases better productivity but
then you want to bring it in during rain
filling anyway so the irrigated paddy is
the most productive ecosystem the rain
fed lowland rice accounts for only 19%
of production but is planted on about
36% of land so you can see that the
ratio is quite different and the rain
for lowland rice is actually a major
ecosystem in many countries and all the
poorest farmers end up planting on
either rain fed lowland or the upland
and the deep water environments where
they have no control over water so
control over water in the rice
production system means that you have
the potential to manager your the
management is is usually more
sophisticated and you're not dependent
on on rain walk on rainfall so now I
have to introduce you to at least a
couple of these ecosystems so I can go
on and explain further many people look
at the paddy system and they think what
are we gonna do we can't produce any
rice in the future look at that standing
water we don't have enough water on the
planet to continue to produce rice in
this way so I just want to walk back a
little bit and explain something that
you may already know and some some of
you may not know but the paddy system
has evolved partly to take advantage of
wetland so there's land all over all
over the world of course but a lot of
the land in in Asia actually is right on
the on the edges of rivers there are a
lot of major rivers that flood every
year and the only crops that can survive
in those flooded areas the only major
cereal crop that can survive is rice and
the other the other real explanation for
why people flood and want to continue
flooding the land is because it's the
oldest form of weed control that we know
so if you have a crop that can grow in
standing water and as I've said rice
it's the only major cereal that can do
that then when you bring water up to a
certain level you do two things you
drown out most of the weed species if
they're not related closely related to
rice or if they're not an aquatic weed
and you provide
in water stagnant water when it goes
anaerobic we'll go we'll push the pH to
pH 7 and that optimizes the availability
of nutrients in the rice paddy
so having flooded rice standing water an
anaerobic situation you give rice an
advantage over weeds you give it almost
the perfect nutrient supply and you're
using land they could not be used for
anything else and that's sort of the
history in a package of why we produce
or why the world has moved towards this
kind of production and I just want to
mention that the reason rice can do this
is because it's capable of taking oxygen
down through the from the chute down to
the route through the Rankine themselves
but it has to have a chute above the
water line in order to be able to do
that because it has to access what
oxygen from the air so it oxygenates its
own routes by this system of passing
oxygen through now one of the other
really big problems with a rice paddy
today although it's optimal for growing
rice is that among the microbial
populations in the rhizosphere and in
the paddy as a whole in these anaerobic
soils are the methanogens that are
pumping out methane and that puts a lot
of pressure on the rice community to
along with the lack of fresh water to
move out of the irrigated system so I
just want you to understand that when we
think about moving out of the paddy
system we're going to have to deal with
things like weeds and nutrient disorders
that the rice community has not had to
deal with as its as its bread Rice's for
these irrigated systems so you think
about the other extreme if you have
control over water and you can irrigate
you're very productive the other extreme
is that you live in these upland Virata
and these upland areas this is the
absolute poorest part of the rice
producing community this is a
slash-and-burn field in Laos and there's
very poor soils throughout this part of
Southeast Asia and when you slash and
burn you only get about two or three
years of production before you have to
move out and leave the land fallow but
the origin of upland rice is quite
interesting because these
Rice's have evolved in these
environments for thousands of years and
people have learned to make selections
these are usually traditional varieties
these are not you're not professionally
bred and there's a lot of manual weeding
and a lot of anxiety about drought so I
show you this picture this is these are
Lao and allow and community in the
slash-and-burn Hills but there are other
parts of the world that grow upland rice
in a very different way and this picture
shows you this our fathers of Brazil so
when they cleared parts of the Amazon
they started planting rice in these
cerrado areas which are upland in the
sense that they're very dry and they
plant rice with a usually they plant it
the way we do in the United States are
completely mechanized this is they flash
then they burned the Amazon and they go
in and and early on before they started
planting pastures they planted rice and
they planted upland rice and they
planted it with machines and they left
it there and they let the weeds compete
and they didn't irrigate and they didn't
worry anything about and they came back
in at the end of the season and
harvested and they got something there
so they started breeding their varieties
for this very extreme upland Brian
ecosystem and those varieties today are
very very in demand especially through
parts of West Africa where rice
consumption is growing the fastest okay
and the only other ecosystem I'm going
to talk about is the rain fed lowland
ecosystem and this one has benefits and
and and some very severe challenges so
what you see in the top left is the
drought 'add area this is a rain for
lowland field where hasn't rained for a
while and this gentleman is actually
replanting trying to fill in areas where
his rice is thinning due to the drought
and you will see people going in and
trying to replant seedlings in these
areas hoping that the rains are going to
come in the lower right you see the
flash floods which is the opposite
problem and this is constantly a problem
and it's a growing problem with climate
variability where you have both drought
and
submergence in the same season and
traditionally people had a rainy season
in a dry season they planted very
different Rice's during the rainy and
the dry but now they're getting rain
during the dry season and and drought
during the wet season and we're having
to breed for things that can that can
withstand both droughts and flooding in
the same season on the opposite poles
you see problem soils that are in parts
in the one is and the top right is in
Columbia the lower left is in Liberia
but these problems are very similar
where you have iron toxicity
unavailability of phosphorus and things
that go along with acid soil problems
and those those the breeding in those
areas is actually also a very
interesting endeavor and one in which
I've been very involved and continue to
be involved this one on the lower left
is a picture of the iron toxic fields in
Liberia and you can see a few varieties
in the front rows that are actually
doing quite well in that soil but
there's been a long history of people
looking for tolerance to iron toxic
soils in the lab Arriba which is the
rice that was domesticated in that part
of the world anyway just to move on so
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
geography of these ecosystems and then
tell you something about the breeding so
that the geographical distribution of
these ecosystems if you just look at
that map you see a bunch of blue dots
those are the irrigated fields and
they're concentrated throughout the high
producing areas of China India and
Indonesia those three large producers in
the world you also see some blue dots a
little bit down in Uruguay in South
America in Madagascar in a couple of in
Mali there's a few areas in Senegal
where they where they irrigate and then
in the United States but what you see
throughout most of Africa and and parts
of South America are blue and red dots
indicating the rain fed lowland and the
rain fed and the upland which is of
course rain fed in a sense so the parts
of the world that are producing rice
outside of the irrigated system those
are the parts of the world where rice
consumption is growing the fast
and they as you see they don't have
controlled irrigation so breeding for
rain fed lowland and all of the income
in problems that come along with it is
actually serving servicing a great part
of the world you'll also notice that
within in Asia you see Southeast Asian
in vast parts of India and the fall
where you have rain fed and and upland
systems so these are the parts of the
world where the breeding has not been
very efficient in terms of the Green
Revolution the green revolution reading
those semi-dwarf that went out are all
require controlled water and controlled
fertilizer pesticide and and usually the
beginnings of mechanized labor so when
we aligned the geography of ecosystems
with the climate risk map of course you
see that they're on quite expectedly
across these areas where we're talking
about rice production being focused in
these problem areas with what we call
non ideal growing conditions meaning
there the rain fed lowland and the
uplands those are the areas also that
are being exposed to the highest climate
risk
so what are the rice production
challenges so you know I've worked my
whole life really it's funny to be
working on rice and talking about rice
breeding here in Ithaca New York because
most people don't think about it every
day and they're certainly not that
familiar with these environments but for
me this has been my life and I and I and
I think a lot about what the production
challenges are in the parts of the world
where rice is not only a source of food
but it's also a livelihood and a
cultural way of life so the rice
production challenges that we face are
to accelerate the breeding of high
yielding climate-resilient and resources
sufficient for these different
environments we have to reimagine how
rice is managed and this is a huge
endeavor that involves many people some
of whom are in this room thinking a lot
about agronomy and water management and
also thinking about when and where rice
is produced it's interesting that China
is already opening up new rice
production areas in the northern part of
China north of Beijing counting on
global warming to move their rice
production zone from the south farther
north as the world as the climate warms
we're also in in the process and very
actively so here at Cornell of
developing predictive models to help
optimize a genotype by environment by
management by microbe and that's
predominantly the methane producing
microbes to optimize those interactions
in future rice production environments
and then to improve the product the
connectivity among breeders farmers
Miller's service providers input vendors
policy makers and consumers and there's
a lot of work going on right now as you
know I wear another hat which is the
director of the digital AG initiative
here at Cornell there's a lot of work
going on in digital AG especially in
Indian and China to try to leapfrog over
some of the problems that they're
encountering with the traditional forms
of extension and outreach to use digital
technologies more wisely to try to help
make these transitions that are going to
be needed to feed their people Oh
and I did want to say so I have these
themes of genetic diversity resilience
and resource use efficiency and today
I'm going to give you some examples that
are going to interweave some of these
ideas as we go forward so those three
themes will be coming back around so I
think it was Jim who said I when I
graduated from Cornell with my PhD I
moved with my family and my two little
kids to the Philippines and if you're a
rice breeder this is the most beautiful
thing you can do is look outside of your
lab and see all the rice paddies right
there you can imagine all the
experiments that you might want to do
those are those electrophoresis units
that was RFLP days that was southern
analysis that was in the early 90s
so our RFLP map consists of a hundred
and thirty-five RFLPs and it had taken
us two years with three people working
24/7 in order to produce that map so you
have to kind of think back to what the
early technology was like and as Jim
said I did a lot of training and during
those early years we not only trained in
Erie but I actually went out to most of
the national programs and in the early
nineties China was was in a very very
very different place than it is today
and trained many of the people who are
today ministers of agriculture and doing
wonderful things for their country and
it was it was back in that in those days
when I don't think any of us could have
possibly imagined what that country
would do in terms of agriculture so my
time at Erie was also punctuated by my
love of the team banking all that it
represents so that's just a picture of a
brick-and-mortar building the gene bank
actually isn't in that building it's
beneath that building the gene banks
it's in an earthquake-proof
vault underneath that building and my
lab was in that building so all I had to
do was go downstairs and there were a
hundred and eighty thousand different
accessions and they were just sitting
there these seed packs in you know most
of them on youth we didn't know much
about them
usually they had passport information
which is that you know where they were
collected when they were collected and
sometime
you knew a little bit about some of the
morphological traits but you really
didn't know much about them
so there was this sort of enticing
opportunity to use this stuff but where
to begin when there 180,000 of them so
one of the things you would do of course
was think about the Ecology's and from
which they'd been collected that would
tell you something about the genetics
you could think about the geography and
that might tell you something you could
also think about any comments that had
been made and registered on the seed
packs when they were collected about
what farmers used these different rice
varieties for but my point is and I'll
come back to this at the end is I've
been fascinated by the idea that
traditional farmers had a kind of closer
communion with the land and with the
ecosystem and with the challenges then
most of us have today and therefore that
there was a lot embedded in these seeds
that as we could just extract that
information it would be useful to to us
as breeders now the other thing is that
of course when I went to Erie I had to
decide what to do and I we had a nice
map we had all hundred and thirty-five
markers that was a big deal but there
were a lot of challenges that that
needed to be addressed and so the
Rockefeller Foundation who was funding
my position at Erie had done a study to
determine which traits were the major
constraints to rice production in the
environments in which they were
interested and they had helped to target
my work in the work of many others
aguirre so that the next part of this
story is about what traits what
discoveries and what outcomes we have
seen over the last that was in 1990 so
if I calculate that I think that's over
25 years the over that period of time so
one of the first traits of interest with
the concept of roots and roots of course
have something to do with water and
nutrients and anchoring and all kinds of
things but nobody had really got a very
good handle on the genetics of roots at
that time and so that was one of those
tantalizing opportunities but she see
whether these different root structures
which you see in this photograph
could actually be tracked retractable as
genetic characteristics of the plant we
also looked at salinity and submergence
tolerance and iron toxicity tolerance in
a variety of things that had to do with
the soils in these rain fed areas and I
was a pathologist coming out of a
pathology background so I was also very
interested in diseases that first one is
rice blast the other one to the side is
the bacterial blight and then the green
leaf hopper is a transmitter of a virus
the yellow model virus and so these were
early on of the tongue grow virus I'm
sorry these were early on on the kind of
traits that I was looking at and I had a
relationship with a guy who was a soil
scientist there and I through that I
developed an interest in understanding
nitrogen fixation and the rhizosphere of
rice and it turned out that this was
genetically tractable and we published
the very very first paper showing that
you could track genes in the plant that
correspond to the ability to fix or
stimulate nitrogen fixation in the
rhizosphere this is associate of
nitrogen fixation this is not nodular
but there's object there was obviously
some kind of exudate coming out of those
roots we didn't have the tools at that
time to study further what either what
the exudates were nor which microbes
were doing the fixation but i just
wanted to mention this paper was
published as you see here in 1995 so
that was a very early start and the
material that can be used to pursue that
today if I were looking at microbiomes
today that's one of the things I would
certainly pursue I was also fascinated
by domestication and as I said the early
landraces so
geneticists in a breeder do you have to
do a lot of crossing while crossing and
rice you see this picture you have to
actually mask you late every single
floor at that you're going to cross and
it's quite a laborious thing you clip
you clip the the floor at just before
the anthers are up to the top and then
you can make your crosses it's done it's
still done manually throughout all all
cross eery and we were developing
populations in those days mostly by
parental populations that were the
source of QTL mapping remember this was
1990 okay and this was a big deal
because this was an opportunity to get
at traits genetically that had only been
able to be under selection by breeders
at the phenotypic level and so we were
looking for parents that were of course
they had trait contrast so one pace
susceptible or resistant they had to be
genetically divergent because we only
had a hundred and thirty-five RFLPs and
you want those rfl peas to be
polymorphic so if you take two lines
that are very closely related you
wouldn't have enough markers to cover
the genome to do a QTL analysis so a lot
of these were indica by japonica crosses
they had to be crossable we wanted fast
generation time because we were making
these immortal recombinant inbred
populations and I won't go on about the
details of this but I just want to say
that many of the populations that we
made in the early 90s when I first went
to Erie are still the basis of what is
being used to derive and clone genes
today and also to drive a lot of the
breeding that I'll talk about in a
moment
these were indica by tropical japonica
crosses the countries of origin were
things like the co 39 by more bear con
they were from India and from Cote
d'Ivoire though they were irrigated by
upland crosses they segregated for all
kinds of pests and diseases they
segregated for root structure they
segregated for drought tolerance they
segregated for seed size all kinds of
things and so the the bottleneck of
course was phenotyping because you could
genotype one population if you could
create the population and it would take
several years but you had two or three
seasons a year so you could do
fairly rapidly so all I'm gonna say is
we created several populations and those
populations are in fact a source of
wealth today so if you can get your
hands on them they're publicly available
and if you're ever working on rice and
I'll tell you more about the kinds of
resources we've built these are really
good opportunities and I will say I have
the seeds right here at Cornell should
anybody want to pursue it so one of the
early papers was this paper called
locating genes associated with root
morphology and drought avoidance in rice
V a linkage to molecular markers and my
graduate student Mike shampoo who you
see up in the upper right-hand corner
led this work so it was published in 95
and I only got to Erie in 1990 and I was
a lot of work and I want to just walk
through what we did so we grew rice in
the greenhouse using these PVC pipes
because we were measuring route depth
and doing some character some
calibrations on route thickness we grew
them in
aeroponics we didn't have hydroponics
but we had aeroponics and if you look at
the lengths of those roots those are
only six week old plants these were
because we had an upland variety in our
in our cross we also grew them in the
field and withheld water so it's what we
call manage stress so we were able to
apply stress when we wanted to because
we had irrigation control and then it
was all RFLPs and so RFLP is of course
our really cumbersome and really slow
and you can see that uh kyushu they're
grinding the tissue on liquid nitrogen
and we produced this this is the map as
it was the map that I produced that in
here at Cornell before I went there
there's the I think we had about 150
markers in those days and those little
boxes you see to the left of each of the
12 chromosomes are indicating where we
had let's say QTL is associated with
root morphology either from these
greenhouse or aeroponics and where they
overlapped is the the coloration or the
barbershop holes on the chromosomes
where they overlapped with a field level
drought so we were starting to show that
you could find regions of chromosomes
where you could associate root traits
and root morphological characteristics
with performance under drought in the
field and this was absolutely
revolutionary when I took this result to
my boss and URI he looked at me I won't
name him very famous rice breeder he
looked at me and he said Susan qtls
are a figment of your imagination and
you'll notice he was not on the list of
authors but I will note that one of the
people who is on this list of authors I
will he will come back into the story a
little later so no to Dave McGill okay
so then I'm going to highlight this
little region at the bottom of
chromosome 9 because part of the story
I'm going to tell that has to do what
they've mikael comes back around and
that at the bottom of chromosome 9 that
QTL comes back around anyway so we had a
lot of cleaning and counting and
measuring of roots and I had a team or
Mike shampoo had a team of people that
were all involved and this team of
people would work day and night to cut
we had plastic bags in the PVC pipes we
would cut them at certain depths we
would wash measure way and and with a
caliper measure the width of these roots
to look at root characteristics
meanwhile this is a extraction of DNA
this was a lot of DNA you needed a lot
of DNA to do southern analysis and all
of these were p32 labeled blots so many
of you are shaking your head so I know
you've been around as long as I have
anyway this was a tremendous challenge
it was as we could see very clearly the
scientific potential of our mapping our
QTL analysis and marker-assisted
selection was right on the horizon but
this process was really slow we had to
generate by parental population we had
to do phenotyping and genotyping and
that was RFLPs it was really laborious
and it was very costly the enzymes had
to come in through Philippine customs
it was nothing like the work that we do
today and each population segregated for
only two alleles so we started making
lots of different populations because
everybody was sure that their particular
combination was the one that would be
most important so many people so many
moving parts so many expensive reagents
and so little connectivity so
information didn't move that easily
because these were pre-internet days and
so data sharing was difficult data
management was beginnings of Excel files
but data analytics we didn't have the
computational power we have today so all
of this made it into a way I started
thinking this is not going to help
reading this is taking way too long it's
way too expensive and we're not making
the kind of progress meanwhile the
breeders were going along independently
and we work completely irrelevant I
disagreed with my boss that we that
these were figments of our imaginations
but we were clearly not on the breeding
pipeline anyway I came back to Cornell
after five years in Erie and genomics
was moving down the road we were moving
out of RFLPs and moving into SSRS and
one of my grand visions was to be able
to genotype the gene Bank a theory I
thought wouldn't that be wonderful if we
could just genotype the gene bank we
could make digital selections as to
which kinds of materials we wanted to
use and it wasn't exactly as easy as it
is today but we did get it our first NSF
grant to build a road map of natural
variation in rice based on obviously a
selection of the materials in the gene
bank and we asked some questions how
much diversity is there in sativa how is
it organized and where is it found and
that you've already seen the maps and
the distributions of Ecology's so now we
wanted to add a molecular genotypic
layer to overlay on what we thought we
knew based on phenotype and adaptation
and what can we learn about genotype
phenotype associations can we start
making predictions and what knowledge
and tools do we need to accelerate
breeding and the management of new rice
varieties given that RFLPs were not
going to do the job
so the first thing we did was to collect
a sample of diversity from the gene bank
based on mostly geography and the
focused on land races he had some elites
in there but a lot of land races because
that's where the maximum amount of
variation was after all
so our collection was from across the
world we were using SSRS and then we
moved quickly into snips and I think our
lab here at Cornell has been in the
vanguard of providing markers to
everyone in the world we've never
protected them we've put everything into
the public domain and even today there
isn't a QTL paper that's published that
isn't using the markers out of the
Cornell Lab so I've been very proud
actually when I go around the world have
so many people tell me that they're so
grateful that they were able to use this
this technology as it came out so what
is the first thing we did of course we
looked at the sub population structure
so Tyva and it's well known that there
are two varietal groups that japonica
and the indica and the picture in the
upper right hand corner shows you what
my breeding colleagues taught me when I
first went to Erie they said there are
three sub populations the Javan Iike the
japonica and the indica and the Jovanka
is simply the tropical version of
temperate japonica so those two are the
japonica's and then there was this thing
called indica and they told me everybody
in the world who produces high quality
high yielding rice is producing indica
rights okay what do I know fine we did
some analysis using our first of all our
SSRS and we saw sort of the same thing
you know we saw the japonica group and
we saw the indica group but didn't quite
conform to the picture that they had
painted for me and you can see that the
tropical japonica and the temperature
ponic of the blue and the green here on
the left are very closely related in the
PCA and in fact they are very distinct
in the minds of the Erie breeders
because they grow in such different
environments but they're very closely
related evolutionarily meanwhile this
huge group that they said was indica
turns out to have two very distinctive
evolutionarily distinctive subgroups but
they're not well different
Shadid either in terms of their
geography where they grow nor in terms
of their morphology and they're easily
crossable so one is called indica and
the other is called ouch which is a
Bengali word for the season of the year
in which these rice is grown now the
ouch subpopulation as it turns out had
always been considered part of indica
but from this PCA I think you can see
that evolutionarily it is almost as
different from indica as the tropical
japonica is from indica so this was a
discovery it went in it flew in the face
of all that was known about rice
genetics and furthermore we applied the
molecular markers to the kind of
material that was being grown in the US
which is high yielding and subtropical
and everybody called it indica and we
showed that it's all tropical japonica
everything grown in the u.s. is tropical
japonica there's no indicas grown in the
US so that was revolutionary and then on
top of it all I don't know if you see
this little thing called aromatic in the
middle that little purple that cluster
of dots those are the famous basmati the
supreme quality rice which is exported
which everybody most people in the world
really value and it showed that actually
the aromatic is not indica it's always
called indigo because as long slim
grains and it's not indica and it's not
japonica in fact it's an admixture
between ouch
and japonica and that was even more
heretical for the Indians who prized
this rice and the and the Pakistanis who
prized this rice as being of indica
origin and it's just been an interesting
road for me because I had no
preconception about any of this and I
have no national identity found up in it
but things didn't sort out the way that
we thought they did and it helped
explain why it was so difficult to make
basmati by indica crosses because
actually basmati is more japonica like
than it is indica like okay enough of
that
so here
geographical distribution and I just
want to say if you if your step back
like I hope you can see this slide
there's a lot of red and yellow in the
top right corner in the Asian on the
asian continent subcontinent and around
much of the rest of the world in Africa
and both North and South America it's
mostly light blue the light blue is the
tropical japonica and the red and the
yellow are the ocean the indica and so
you'll see that the AO in the indica
which are predominantly grown in the
tropical zones there in Asia are
associated with this high yielding the
high yielding types that we're seeing
but what what is interesting here is
that it's the tropical japonica's that
are grown throughout most of the rest of
the world some of which are very very
high yielding as we see in the United
States and in parts of South America and
so it scrambled people's understanding
of both what we could do with our germ
plasm and how we were combining it and
to some extent it helped challenge some
thinking if there is a distinct
population which you see as these bright
yellow circles centered in the
Bangladeshi river delta and in east
india if that is a distinctive
evolutionarily distinctive type of rice
what is it that makes it so special or
isn't it special
many people claim to grow our varieties
today but part of the rest of the story
that I'm going to tell you is what we've
been learning as we start looking for
stress tolerant genes almost a hundred
percent of which are coming from the our
sub population today so we've
constructed diversity panels and our
diversity panels some of which we
constructed here with NSF funding in
collaboration with our colleagues in
Arkansas at the USDA and some of which
we constructed it Erie they consist of
all five subpopulations the indica the
ouch the tropical tapana cut temperature
Hanukkah and aromatic and these
varieties are they're mostly traditional
varieties have all been purified for at
least two generations and then bred
sorry purified from single panicles for
two generations and we now have inbred
sources of seed that can be distributed
and my lab here thanks to NSF funding
put seven hundred thousand snips on all
1600 of these lines and these are now
available as the basis for Association
mapping in rice the eary group then in
collaboration with with China has now
added an additional three thousand and
those were fully sequenced so we have
collectively about 4,500 lines of rice
which have been purified are publicly
available and have genotypes so the beg
for the rest of the community is what do
you want to do about phenotyping you can
phenotype these lines you can request
them you could request subsets you get
for free you get your genotypes over the
Internet
what kind of phenotypes that we want to
look at and we've looked at all kinds of
phenotypes and it's a very large
collective now of people who can use
these lines or subsets of these lines to
phenotype whatever they want in the
field in the growth chamber in any
country in the world that allows them to
import those Rice's and my lab has been
doing quite a bit on panicle structure
on seed size shape and color on stresses
related to water on things like ons this
shows the barbed on you may have
followed some of that work on disease
and resistance on canopy temperature and
then on this fast growth in response to
rise
water lots and lots of different
phenotypes and so the beauty of this is
that the students who used to come into
my lab could choose a phenotype of
interest and they had material at their
fingertips to work with and then there's
the roots so the roots are still some of
my favorites and one of the things we
did was 15 years after our first root
phenotyping experience in the
Philippines was to work with Randy Clark
who was part of Leon coaches lab at the
USDA and Janelle Joan who was a PhD
student in my lab Randy built this cool
little um this was just the early
version of it it's even cooler now but
this automated or semi-automated
phenotyping system where we grew our
plants I think you can see the yeah
through these plants in a gel um gum so
that's a that's like a sort of clear
John gum and then we would rotate them
we put the cylinder apart of a big
cylinder actually in water and then we
had that was on a revolving table and
then we had the camera and could take
revolving pictures of this so that we
could reconstruct 3d images from these
2d captured images and so this was the
early days of what we're calling today
if I throughput phenotyping and image
capture and then automated image
processing and what I just want to say
is we would take 40 images per plant as
it turned on its on its base
they were imaged over different days
because it's completely non-destructive
and then the software that Randy built
the root Reader 3d software could
reconstruct single 3d images of each
individual's root system and then
because you could have replicated these
were all inbred lines and you had
replicated versions of this you could
start to look at population level
genome-wide associations using these
reconstructed 3d images and this was
really quite a powerful technique and
when I think back to the days at Erie
where we were 40 people using a caliper
to measure roots and
couldn't do anything that was
non-destructive this was completely
non-destructive what we were able to do
was the following so this is just one
example we were looking at root system
architecture we used 373 individuals
from all the different sub populations
we measured 13 different traits over
three days in the four sub populations
we didn't use aromatic we were not using
the buzz Mahdi's we were using just the
indigo D ouch the temperate in the
tropical japonica now the 12 chromosomes
of rice are here and the big lines are
the qtls because we had by parental
crosses as well as our association
mapping panel and the little tiny red
ones are the G was qtls or the G was
signal what you can see in some cases
the G was signals overlap with the QTL
in other cases they sort of expand it
and in other cases they were completely
independent of course the by parental
cross was IR 64 by also sanik captured
only two alleles whereas the association
mapping panel captured many alleles so
you can appreciate that they weren't all
entirely overlapping but really one of
the take homes of this slide is that the
QTL resolution was so much lower than
the G was resolution and so for the same
population size you would get month but
much better resolve regions of interest
if you looked if you use the G waz as as
compared to the QPL or the by parental
TTL so here's a man Manhattan plot and
what you see along and I think most of
you probably know how to read him and
hatton plot but these are the 12 Pro
Mazzone and there were 700,000 snips and
they're all lined up in order linear
order as they are arrayed across and
this is the negative law of probability
so this is just essentially a kind of
p-value for an association between the
the snip and the phenotype and here is
the most significant snip up at 10 to
the minus 7 on chromosome 3 corresponds
to this region on chromosome 3 it was
aji was hit and it's an association for
route length in the indica sub
population and when you look at what
these beautiful concatenated images look
like now don't get
there is no difference here okay I'm
showing you where there is no difference
and it's the snip that I'm showing you
is 66 KB away from the peak snip but
these the point here is these are
concatenated images this one has 39
different individuals replicated to form
a concatenated image of what the root
length was in these indicas these are
the indicas that carry the a allele at
this snip and the indicas that carried
the b allele at the same sniff there
were 118 of them and the two root
lengths are roughly the same but when
you move over and you look at the peak
snip which is the snip that was
significantly associated with the
difference in the phenotype in the root
length what you see is it that the a
allele carries the short route length
and the B allele has a longer route
length and there's a slightly different
number because of course there were
recombinant between this snip and miss
snip so the number of plants in each
group has shifted slightly now to take
homes here to the resolution is about 60
KB actually if you look at the ones
in-between you start to see a difference
and so I'm just showing you you can see
little remnants of the difference but
it's not as significant and the p-value
is not as high so you have a pretty good
resolution in rice if you have a 60 KB
resolution you're still talking about
several genes and really you have 60 K
be on either side so at a you have
roughly a hundred 120 KB you have at
least 20 genes in that region but you've
narrowed your search space considerably
now meanwhile okay we were doing this
work here our NSF funding we were very
excited about the new phenotyping
possibilities we were moving quickly to
get a much higher resolution view of the
associations between genotype and
phenotype and our colleagues at Erie had
continued down the road of the by
parental mapping for 15 years and they
were doing amazing work measuring not
only with calipers but they'd also
started to automate their phenotyping
and they were able to do it in the field
which I clearly is not and so some of
the collaborations that I've had
these years I've kept me in in touch
with this work and I just want to say
that while I was doing the work here
they were doing the work there and one
day a pag the two groups were getting up
I got up to give a talk and my colleague
Eddie or he got to give up talk right
after me and we realized we were doing
the same work he was doing in the field
and we were doing it with this automated
phenotyping the question was are we
discovering any of the same any of the
same region and I just want to show you
that this work involved planting rice
seedlings into a spaghetti colander
which was then planted into a tub which
was sunk into the soil so that you could
manage drought if that's what you wanted
to do and so that you could pull it up
and clean off the roots much as we had
been doing 15 years before at Erie and
what you see is then you could clean off
the roots and then clip the roots and
you could measure them as they came out
of the colander and so the different
phenotype that was being measured by
this group was whether the roots grew
straight down or whether they seemed to
sprawl out across the soil at a
different angle and another group at
area had been doing phenomenal work
looking at what we call phosphorous
uptake it actually is called phosphorous
starvation tolerance and again they had
come back to the understanding that it
was a root phenotype that determined
phosphorous uptaken scavenging ability
so back to my theme about roots and the
next slide shows what the discovery that
was being made by the groups who had
been doing this for 15 years in the
field entailed and it entailed a cross
between IR 64 and a traditional upland
variety from the film the Philippines
called
Kenan Don Fatone and Kenan Dom Patong
had very deep roots because was an
upland variety in IR 64 which is the
quintessential indica out of Erie it is
planted on more acreage even today than
any other rice variety in the world and
it has very shallow roots because it's
grown in the irrigated system and it
doesn't need deeply and he crossed those
two and then he back crossed and intra
breast the region with the largest
effect QTL for deep roots in
the IR 64 background and he created an
near isogenic line of IR six before
carrying one region on chromosome nine
that carried the deep-rooted QTL from
Keenan danke Thome and the trait donor
was of course one of those early land
races that we had selected for one of
those by parental crosses made back in
the early 90s and that was publicly
available and what did he discover when
he cloned that gene he found that this
gene which he calls draw one and many of
you are familiar with this work that a
single base pair deletion in Exxon four
changed the route angle and that change
in route angle so this is the deep
rooted and this is the shallow rooted
and that change in route angle had no
effect in yield under irrigated
conditions but went under moderate
drought the IR 64 could no longer keep
up with yield and the ni L that had that
one introgression on chromosome nine
associated with a cutie L was doing
quite well and under extreme drought
where I are 64 died the ni L was still
able to survive and produce offspring
and so what is really remarkable is he
showed that that one base pair deletion
in exon for that changed the route angle
enhanced brain yield under drought and
he could show it because he developed
the NI ELLs these are pairs of lies that
can go out and be planted in the field
under the same conditions now for those
of you who are wondering what this gene
does it's an unknown protein it says no
it has no and no correspondence to
anything with known function but we do
know that it's negatively regulated by
oxen it shows a higher expression of the
drawn protein causes the downward root
growth so it is quantitative and there
are variants across the in the germ
plasm array that have more or less
production of the draw one protein it's
involved in cell elongation at the root
tip and it localizes to the plasma
membrane and I'm going to move quickly
because I have a feeling I'm running out
of time I want to go on and say and I
hope pen on you is on at in Geneva
because I'm going to feature some of the
work that canal Jew did in he did it
originally at UC Davis but this is an
important story and I really want to
tell it it has to do with the sub-1
aging which confers submergence
tolerance so the one I just talked about
was draw one which is related to the
downward growth of roots which confers
drought tolerance and this is a
different phenotype entirely it has
nothing to do with roots but it this is
a phenotype now that is of the great
importance in the same rain-fed systems
where the drought is important and this
is for submergence tolerance and in this
case the submergence tolerance is
conferred by what they call the sub one
aging and it's not a single base pair
change in a gene of unknown function
it's a complete addition of a new member
of an ethylene response factor gene
family and so in this case canal showed
in his work when he actually cloned this
gene that the sub1a was the new member
the B and C are shared with the
reference genome but a the a gene was
not present at all in the reference
genome which is why it was a challenge
to clone in 2006 and this particular
donor was called fr 13 a it's a now
schland race it carries this incredible
opportunity to survive under submergence
and it basically holds its breath
so it's an ethylene response factor gene
and I want to tell this bit of the story
because if you look at the citation
that's up there some of you may
recognize the name
Kaufman William Ronnie Kaufman
so Ronnie Kaufman was a breeder before
myself and before Dave McGill he was a
Tyria in the 1970s and one of the papers
that he produced in 1981 was called
inheritance of submergence tolerance in
rice and the take home of that paper was
that there was a single major gene
associated with submergence tolerance
and that it would be important in the
range fed lowland areas throughout South
Asia where flash floods were a problem
that was followed by a paper by Dave
mcil who came in as Ronnie's replacement
for the rain for lowland breeding
program at Erie and he published a paper
where he had actually improved
semi-dwarf varieties which were high
yielding varieties by introducing this
gene and for those varieties and dave
mcgill when ronnie came back to Erie
came back to Cornell David Hill took his
place at Erie and was still there when I
went there and dave mcgill was trying to
breed based on phenotype and he had to
flood these things and see which one
survived and it took quite a long time
and so when I got there Dave McGill came
to me and said I know exactly what I
want to do I want to make this
population with this donor because it
survives under its emergence and I want
to do a QTL analysis with your markers
and I want you to give me markers so me
I as a breeder can start moving it into
the backgrounds that I really want and
so that project which again started in
the early 90s took the form of
eventually a cloning project back at the
University of California and canang Zhu
who is today an apple breeder up in
Geneva did this incredible work where he
had to clone a gene that didn't exist in
the reference genome and it took quite
it was quite challenging for him but
once they'd cloned it they were able to
move this gene quite readily into other
backgrounds but let me just say before
they'd cloned the genes they knew where
it was based on the early work and they
had markers and those markers went to
the genome mapping lab that I had
initiated at Erie and people started
putting it into the major varieties that
were planted in the flooded zones across
South and Southeast Asia and so they had
a line in the Schwerner background which
is one of the most commonly planted
farmer preferred varieties throughout
this rain-fed lowland area in India and
Bangladesh they had put the sub 1 gene
into through back crossing had put it
into SH warna and those varieties were
already in the early testing phases and
what I'm showing you here is what
happens under a drought or sorry under
submergence of 10 days though 30 days
after planning the crop is
beautiful and then a flash flood comes
and sits on top of the rice for ten days
and it pretty much wipes out the shore
now it doesn't have the sub one in it
the sub one has come from a now schland
race called fr 13a and when you have
that introgression in your line your
material holds its breath until the
water subsides it can do that for about
14 days and then when the water subsides
it can regrow and this saves people from
what they're doing here is they're
trying to go back in and replant that
field in order to salvage their crop for
that season where here they don't have
to replant so that is the value of this
gene and it took a lot of foresight
because the first crosses were made in
the early 90s and the gene was cloned in
2006 and then the back the back crossing
had already begun at Erie once they had
markers from the earlier by parental QTL
mapping and what you should what we're
showing here is the number of different
backgrounds that they use or
introgression of that gene as dave mcil
with great foresight thought if we're
successful this gene needs to be put
into different backgrounds for different
countries where different farmers have
different brain quality preferences and
if we get it into the varieties that
they already like then it'll be an easy
swap for them we're not asking them to
do anything different than they've
always already done will make near
isogenic lines and they'll see for
themselves whether this is better and so
this started at Erie and this was set
these works F he also was a student out
of my lab who then was at Erie doing
this work and they moved it through back
crossing into a variety of different
backgrounds and what you see in this
graph is that the sub one varieties
always outperform the non sub one
varieties and under increasing days of
submergence although they all decline a
bit the submergence quality quality the
sub one varieties always do better and
so within five years the first release
is the actual first variety releases
were in 2009 within five years ten
million farmers and ten million hectares
of rain fed
a flash flood prone rain-fed little and
land who are covered with sub one
varieties so the backgrounds are
different this one gene is the same and
there were four hundred and fifty
different government NGO farmer
organization and seed companies that
were involved in getting this material
out from Arian from that breeding
program out to farmers and that is one
of the record up takes and I think the
fact that they chose to do this by not
about redefining the variety just
redefining one trait helped with that
uptake and I just want to say that they
had a whole strategy for doing this and
being part of a strategy any of you who
do work that even if you start by
cloning a gene if you can plug into one
of these networks your work may take off
and really have an impact and it's very
important that you understand the
strategy behind the work that you do
because these strategies are not simple
they involve many many many people
public sector private sector government
NGO as we were saying and in this case
here are a few pointers the sub one gene
was interest in the farmer preferred
varieties as I've said each one
different for a different target site
the flood prone areas themselves that
were being targeted were identified
using remote sensing GIS and ground
intelligence in other words there are a
whole slew of people in the government
already using digital technologies to
figure out where the most likely
occurrence of certain stresses is
especially with climate change at-risk
villages then we're targeted for a
variety that we call participatory
varieties selection or PDS and this was
all prior to release so it was part of
the selection process and they used male
and female farmer input to make sure
that women were on the side of preparing
this on the culinary side or who were
involved with the transplanting were
involved in a decision-making they also
included local checks so everybody could
see for themselves whether these
varieties were something they wanted or
not and instead of trying to plant one
target area with a large expanse they
chose to distribute many kids
about five kgs of seed per village they
were provided to thousands of targeted
villages to allow for farmer-to-farmer
dissemination of seed the seed is all
inbred farmers save their own seed and
when it's good it moves very quickly
from farmer to farmer so they didn't
require seed companies in the in the
beginning and the coordination that was
required was quite considerable and this
was all coordinated under what they
called the stress of project thanks to
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
and the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation is very big right now in
trying to provide the kind of
coordination that is needed between the
scientists the breeders the government
and agencies and the technology exchange
that is that is required to really make
this kind of thing work so I'm coming
down to the end of my talk and I just
want to say there's a lot of you know a
lot of beautiful stories about the one
gene at a time
that make a big difference in sub-1 and
the semi dwarf before it and the pistol
which is the phosphorus starvation
tolerance gene and others I could tell
many of these stories but really the
question is is one gene at a time enough
we have to think about what's happening
around us and the climate is changing
faster and people are fleeing the
countryside in droves partly due to
climate change and the civil unrest and
the disasters that follow particularly
as I go back to the think about the
beginning of the talk because the export
market for ice is so inelastic that when
there's a crop failure due to climate
change
there isn't enough in the international
market to make the rice available that
people need so there's a massive kind of
feeling of unrest and an accelerated
desire to move breeding forward so I
just I know I've gone a little bit over
time and I apologize I just want to take
you down this road so we have the rise
of the Walmart model we're all affected
by it and breeding is affected by it as
well you
infinite amounts of data on every aspect
of your subject matter
maybe it's toothpaste right Walmart it's
not all about breeding and and other
people that that need our products you
use machine learning algorithms to
define patterns and generate hypotheses
in other words learn from the data you
validate your models you redefine your
hypotheses by testing on new populations
and new environments you know the way
that Walmart moves is they figure out
what works in one population they look
for the population that's most like it
and they take that exact retail model
and they start applying it somewhere
else and it works really well you use
validated models that to predict
behavior or performance of future
populations and environments and you
beat the competition using data and
intelligence to speed up the delivery of
project of products that people want and
sometimes that they need this model is
the model right now the big data model
that most of us are working under and
it's a challenge we have our parallel
inbreeding in genetics where you collect
lots of data on phenotype on environment
on genotype you develop models as
quickly as you can that integrate all of
those and help you predict the
performance of your lines you
continuously update your models you
iteratively improve them you use
predicted breeding values to increase
selection intensity increase accuracy
and decrease cycle time and then you
modify your breeding design to take
advantage of new efficiencies that's the
name of the game it's the Walmart model
inbreeding and we're all being asked to
try to accelerate for reasons that we
all understand but it's taking us down
this road of more constantly more faster
and hopefully better but it's creating
this two world phenomenon the thing I
call or my colleagues over an
engineering call the digital twin
phenomenon you have breeding pipelines
which are basically a collage of genetic
resources reading populations and
improved lines that are crossed
evaluated selected and recombined in a
recurrent cycle in biological time under
field conditions that material is
physical knowledge about that material
is dynamic and evolutionary
and side by side you have a genomics
pipeline which is a collage of
algorithms and analytical procedures
that process reprocess intersect and
integrate data in parallel computing
streams generating a series of models
and predictions about future performance
to guide selection the information is
representational and it resides in
cyberspace and hopefully it reflects the
reality the physical reality of the food
that we need to produce in order to
maintain livelihoods and to maintain
adequate human health but the challenge
for our generation or for actually I
would say the younger generation is
really the challenge of how you're going
to integrate automation and Big Data
into a conception of the world that is
still maintains touch with reality we
have digital tools data streams
simulation and prediction and it's
completely revolutionized the way we see
the world and our ability to make
predictions about the future world it's
imposing disruptive change and I
question as I come to the close of this
is can we integrate the best of both
worlds can we continue to discover
diverse alleles and mechanisms that you
confer resilience and nutrient use
efficiency and also to use genomic
selection or genomic prediction to
efficiently combine them with all the
alleles that we have for yield and
quality in our elite breeding material
and I want to just end by this these few
thoughts I have at the end of this
presentation which is that beyond
breeding and statistics rice is also a
bridge to human history and deeply held
cultural values and perspectives it is a
source of beauty it's an essential
natural resource it's a product that
provides livelihoods promotes health and
well-being and it's the foundation for
partnership education and innovation and
for me a source of inspiration so with
that I thank you all for listening and I
thank the group that I've worked with
and my funding sources over many years
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu